if you're just joining I just played a  how do I explain this I played a game of  XXL chess I'll play one more just  or even more content  against angry space void the only  Challenger  I was playing duck chess earlier we had  a fun duck collab with  minlay  yeah  foreign  [Music]  how to do this  I'm trying to figure out how the camel  moves  okay so for for people that maybe just  tuned in and are new to this game this  is a camel it moves like a knight but  instead of two in over one it's three  and over one  so this camel so I'm like I'm attacking  the pawn except no I'm not  because the pawn is defended by the  bishop  I think we call this a hawk  okay  I think this is checkmates  GG  this came to mind the other day  I didn't want to like say what my plan  was to reveal it but uh  Gigi the four moves smother mate I think  that's the quickest possible Checkmate  in this game  smothered camel mate  don't mess with my camel